please welcome the chairman and CEO of
the Motion Picture Association of
America mr. Jack Valenti
when the nation's future is in danger
and the dagger is at the nation's belly
ordinary young men and women perform
extraordinary acts of heroism one man
more than any other living American
understand these young people who
confront fear and death in order to
preserve freedom in this free and loving
land for generations of Americans yet
unborn he embodies the American spirit
which has defined our nation since its
inception from the very birth year of
the Republic he is a chairman of
America's Promise and the Alliance for
youth and the former chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff General Colin
Powell
every generation contains the potential
for greatness for the generation that
came out of the depression that
potential was tested on the battlefields
of World War two had those men and women
failed that test of their greatness we
would live very different lives today to
our and our children's good fortune they
did not fail
instead they triumphed two of the film's
nominated this evening for Best Picture
depicts specific incidents in World War
two but we must remember that every
segment of our American mosaic
contributed to the ultimate victory so
hard and painfully one in the Thin Red
Line director Terrence Malick deals with
the war in the Pacific juxtaposing the
tranquil simple lives of the native
Melanesians of the Solomon Islands
against the vicious mechanized battle
being waged by the courageous soldiers
of Charlie Company fighting an enemy
obsessed with avoiding defeat at any
cost in Saving Private Ryan director
Steven Spielberg brings us violently
face to face with the carnage of war as
he takes his handheld cameras to the
Allied invasion of Omaha Beach on d-day
the 6th of June the story concerns a
squad of soldiers sent behind enemy
lines on an agonizing search to find and
retrieve a mother's sole surviving son
here are scenes from The Thin Red Line
and Saving Private Ryan